[Música]
algunos de ustedes saben que es esto
un poco de imaginación bueno esto es un
riñón
qué
y este riñón se supone que debía estar
en este lado
en el año 2005 sufrí la noticia de que
tenía cáncer de riñón y era una
enfermedad terminal
y en este tiempo pues fue algo un shock
tremendo que te digan oye vas a durar
sólo tres meses
y pues le dije que otros asuntos pero
vayas a donde vayas te van a decir lo
mismo y obviamente surgen ese tipo de
preguntas bueno y porque yo porque a mí
podría haberle pasado a cualquiera y por
qué me tengo que haberme haberme pasado
y asistí a varios grados y en todos me
dijeron sabes qué
esta es la terrible realidad después de
esos días haber muchísimos
cuestionamientos y ya a presión a miento
de otro orden en el cual
obviamente hay te empiezas a cuestionar
te empiezas a poseer muchísimo el porqué
de tu vida y el porqué de todas estas
cosas
y sin entrar en detalles lo que les
puedo decir que hoy en día estamos aquí
soy un sobreviviente soy un
sobreviviente pero aún así no dejo de
cuestionarme desde aquel día y sigo
preguntándome muchas cosas
yo soy ingeniero en alimentos y me tocó
nacer en la generación del no crecí con
la generación del no cuando vas a la
escuela y se te ocurría hacer una
ecuación diferente a la que venía en el
libro obviamente pues estaba reprobado
en la facultad que estudie así era
siempre y a mí me gustaba muchísimo
siempre está desarrollando pues nuevas
formulaciones nuevos procesos nuevas
cosas
y el resultado era invariable no se
puede y no se puede al grado de que
mandarán llevar a mi padre y le dijeron
señor por favor ya ves este muchacho
aquí nada más le está echando a perder
la vida mejor llévelo a otro lado donde
pueda desarrollar alguna habilidad o
algo por el estilo y mi padre que fue mi
guía mi filósofo y mi amigo me dijo
adelante por supuesto que se puede acabe
la carrera
y entré a trabajar en control de calidad
en una empresa y al poco rato estaba
afuera porque no me ha llevado estoy en
gestión de la calidad de nuestra empresa
dure apenas una semana en producción
cuatro meses después me tomé un año
de vagar de
un lado de la frontera de eeuu hasta el
otro lado tuve más de 20 trabajos
en muchas cosas y al final del día
me encontré que tenía yo mi propio
trabajo que finalmente había conseguido
lo que quería que era independiente que
yo podía manejar mis tiempos que yo
podía manejar mi negocio mi pequeño
negocio como yo quería y de repente ya
no era un pequeño negocio de repente
pues empezó a crecer
y obviamente pues llega a una cuestión
monetaria y se supone que te hace feliz
y claro que te da una satisfacción y sin
embargo yo seguía sintiendo ese enorme
hueco dentro de mí de que algo estaba
pasando que no me dejaba realizarme
dejé todo atrás regresé a méxico acabé
mis estudios de literatura me metí a
filosofía finalmente me tiene una
solicitud de una empresa transnacional
me dieron el puesto representante
técnico y por primera vez tuve contacto
con las grandes empresas de mexico en el
área de planificación pastelería
cárnicos chocolates lácteos etcétera
pero lo más sorprendente es de que en
mis manos tenía un cúmulo de materias
primas de ingredientes que en contacto
con la industria me inter me permitían
interactuar y fue cuando empecé a
descubrir que si se podía desarrollar
que sí se podía innovar y la gente con
la que yo trabajaba también estaba
encantada debía desarrollar y que
encontrara esas sinergias que existen y
muchas cosas que se hacían simplemente
porque así se tenían que hacer pues las
empecé a cambiar formulaciones sistemas
procesos etcétera que me permitieron ir
conociendo la mecánica la físico química
y bueno no entraré en detalles de toda
la cuestión
está dentro de la industria de los
alimentos y la verdad ahí me empecé a
sentir un poco más satisfecho y ya no
trabajar a las 8 horas trabajaba con una
pasión inusitada y así dure varios años
de mi vida
pero llegó un punto en esas horas de la
noche que no te puedes dormir y
reflexionas quiero que me está pasando
bueno no puedes estar a gusto con nada y
empecé a ver la otra cara de la moneda
la otra cara de la moneda donde
descubrimos que las empresas son frías
las empresas son insensibles las
empresas están hechas para ganar dinero
y entonces lo que lanzan al mercado pues
es un cúmulo de productos que obviamente
van a saciar su apetito vas a decir esto
es maravilloso y lo que hacen pues se
llenarte la panza
obviamente antes se llenaron con el
marketing
y esa ecuación funciona esa ecuación
funciona pero cuando te das cuenta de
ello dice lo que me está pasando yo no
puedo estar dentro de esto no lo acepto
no puedo continuar siendo parte de esto
y empecé a documentarme de muchas otras
cosas que traen consigo los alimentos
cosas que no las vemos por ejemplo les
diré que descubrir
que de cada 10 litros de agua esto es
una cuestión de norteamérica
9 se utilizan para lo que son pastizales
para animales animales que sabana no los
vamos a comer se van a procesar van a
ser producto terminado y un solo litro
va para consumo humano
también
que de un litro de agua sólo se obtiene
una caloría
realmente no es algo sustentable
que un tercio de la superficie de la
tierra es superficie que también está
destinada a pastizales y que estos
pastizales obviamente ya sabemos que no
son sustentables y que se podría hacer
algo mucho mejor
y para el año 2050 esto se va a duplicar
y así van las cosas les puedo decir
también que no son los autos de un hotel
o carriles ni de los aviones las
industrias más contaminantes del planeta
es la industria de alimentos el 60 por
ciento de la contaminación causada en el
mundo es por la industria de alimentos y
es un dato extremadamente fuerte y yo no
quiero y no quería ser parte de eso
y esa caloría o esa gota fue la que
derramó el vaso y decidí dejar todo
completamente atrás
y no quise seguir destruyendo y me
dediqué a innovar a desarrollar a crear
a crear valor pero con sentido humano
que fue cuando empecé a desarrollar esos
pequeños bloques de conocimiento que
posteriormente se harían ya tangibles y
se convertirían en productos y fue
cuando empecé a trabajar con productos
maravillosos de la naturaleza con granos
ancestrales con chicharrón con vegetales
que les puedo decir con un cúmulo de
ingredientes en los cuales gustosamente
los transformaba los transforma mi
equipo de manera natural hasta
convertirlos en queso en leche un huevo
en carne y todo esto
el principal sello es que miméticamente
deberían ser iguales a un alimento de
origen cárnico pero lo mejor de todo es
que no están hechos para llenar la panza
están hechos para
para que de veras disfrutes para
alimentar y para nutrir y por primera
vez en mi vida fue que me sentí
satisfecho me sentí extremadamente
satisfecho porque al igual que yo hay
mucha gente haciendo esta labor dentro
de otras empresas preocupadas por toda
la cuestión de la alimentación de todas
las consecuencias terribles que tiene
todo esto y que no debemos esperar
a que sea la última llamada a que nos
falle algo en el cuerpo para entender
que debemos debemos de efectuar un
cambio y que ese cambio debe ser de
orden disruptivo
entonces
mucho más allá de este problema existe
otro que es un problema relacionado más
con la psique humana en el hecho de que
llevamos consumiendo por generaciones y
generaciones los mismos alimentos cuando
estamos en nuestra casa nosotros jamás
dudamos de lo que nos dan como podemos
dudar de la comida reanudar nuestros
padres o la que ellos les dieron a la
que nosotros les damos a nuestros hijos
y realmente existe mala información pero
también existe la reticencia la
renuencia de efectuar un cambio de
proporciones mayúsculas siempre es lo
mismo
vamos por las armas pero vayan a la
guerra porque nadie nosotros
realmente hacemos un cambio
realmente hacemos algo activo para ir
adelante a pesar de todos estos hechos
de que nos obligan a cambiar yo encontré
mi misión de vida mi apostolado mi
proyecto de vida y realmente me siento
afortunado por todo eso quiero
transmitirlo a todos ustedes
y antes de terminar esta charla yo lo
que quiero comentarles es que el
alimento es la bendición que la
naturaleza nos ha dado a los seres
humanos
desde que el hombre es hombre sobre la
faz de la tierra ya era cazador y
recolectaba también sus frutos y el día
de hoy
escúchenlo bien nosotros somos las
presas
y lo único que recolectamos es lo que
encontramos en la tienda de la esquina o
en el supermercado y somos esclavos de
esta gran cadena alimentaria
yo quisiera quisiera dejarles un mensaje
si quisiera que alguien de ustedes me
ayudara quien de ustedes puede pasar
aquí al frente para ayudarme común usted
adelante
aquí tenemos
dos botanas
nada más quisiera que leyera no me
pongas propaganda ni buena ni mala de
nadie qué es lo que hice aquí de grasa
ok son 10 gramos totales sobre un
paquete de 3 de 33 gramos estamos
teniendo el 30 por ciento de grasa y de
proteína
ok y ahora puede leer este por cuales
gracias
[Música]
ok aquí estamos hablando de que en
realidad
el contenido es un 20% de proteína
proteínas completamente bio digerible
para el cuerpo humano y no tenemos
absolutamente nada absolutamente nada de
grasa porque porque la grasa al momento
de pre irse
produce más de 2500 componentes muchos
de ellos son cancerígenos
y no tiene en este momento estar
hablando de tantos pero
pero yo no quiero que esto suceda creo
más en la cultura de la prevención los
puedes probar y decir este qué tan
alejado estamos que se puede crear un
producto natural lleno de proteína a
bajo en calorías
seguir adelante
tal vez el sabor no sea el mismo pero
entonces no necesariamente es un cambio
drástico algo malo
la comida gracias a la obra por todo por
tu atención no son para para ti para
votarla
[Música]
el dolor
esto lo generamos
esto lo rellenamos a nuestros hijos
la indiferencia es el es lo peor que
nosotros podemos tener
debemos ir adelante y debemos de saber
que nuevamente se lo repito que el
alimento es una bendición de la
naturaleza seamos congruentes con la
naturaleza seamos congruentes con
nosotros mismos
la vida la vida continúa fluye a través
de una sana alimentación pero la vida la
vida no es sencilla no sólo tenemos que
sobrellevarlo
tenemos algo para ser dignos de vivirla
y recuerden amigos que la vida
la vida solo comienza al final de la
zona de confort
por favor escucha esta última llamada
por su atención
muchísimas gracias niños
[Aplausos]